PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
I JOINED THE FINAL FIVE
FOR DINNER,
AND THINGS GOT EMOTIONAL.
I FEEL SO LUCKY BECAUSE
WE ACTUALLY ARE FRIENDS.
THE GIRLS MET SOUTH AFRICA'S
FASHION ELITE...
HI, I'M KEENYAH.
AND GOT A TASTE OF
KEENYAH'S COMPETITIVE SIDE.
AND KEENYAH LOVED
THE LOCAL CUISINE.
OH, GOT YOU!
YEAH.
IN THE END,
CHRISTINA COULDN'T THAW
HER COLD PERSONA...
I'M NOT FEELING ANYTHING
FROM YOU.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN-- NAIMA,
KEENYAH, KAHLEN AND BRITTANY.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
OKAY, THANKS, BRITT.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
HEY, YOU'RE WELCOME.
THERE ARE FOUR OF US NOW,
AND I THINK KEENYAH AND BRITTANY
HAVE MADE A FRIENDSHIP WHERE
THEY CAN SUPPORT EACH OTHER.
AND KAHLEN HAS BEEN
MY BEST FRIEND
IN THIS COMPETITION.
SHE HAS BEEN
MY EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
YOU ALL ARE SO USED TO
BEING JUDGED BY US, THIS WEEK
YOU'RE GOING TO JUDGE
EACH OTHER.
HAVING MY COMPETITORS
JUDGE ME,
IT WAS VERY HARD, BUT I THINK
OVERALL, IT'S IMPORTANT
IN A COMPETITION.
THE PERSON WHO I THINK
MAY HAVE
THE LEAST POTENTIAL IN THIS,
I WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO SAY NAIMA.
I THINK THERE'S A SHELL
AROUND HER SOMETIMES.
NAIMA'S PERSONALITY IS NOT
VERY OUTGOING.
PEOPLE AREN'T GONNA RELATE
TO HER AS MUCH
AS THEY WOULD RELATE TO LIKE
BRITTANY OR, YOU KNOW, TO ME.
THE WHOLE POINT
OF THAT CHALLENGE WAS TO SEE
HOW MUCH WE'VE LEARNED.
SO IF THAT MEANS I HAVE TO
PINPOINT EVERY LITTLE THING
THAT MAYBE THEY WOULD SAY,
THEN I'M GONNA DO THAT.
THE THING THAT ANNOYS ME
WITH KEENYAH IS SHE DOESN'T PUT
OTHER PEOPLE AHEAD OF HER.
IT'S ALWAYS KEENYAH,
KEENYAH, KEENYAH.
SO I REALLY DIDN'T CARE
WHO WAS MY FRIEND AT THAT TIME.
I WAS REALLY SHOWING THEM
THAT I--
Brittany: I CAN'T BELIEVE
THE WAY YOU SAID--
CAN I FINISH TALKING,
BRITTANY, PLEASE?
I JUST WANT TO FINISH
THIS SENTENCE.
OKAY, DON'T EVER GET RUDE
WITH ME LIKE THAT AGAIN
'CAUSE YOU CUT PEOPLE OFF
ALL OF THE TIME.
I KNOW, I AM LEARNING THAT.
BUT YOU--
I'VE ASKED YOU ALREADY.
I AM NOT FINISHED TALKING,
BUT YOU STILL GO.
WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER SO LONG,
LITTLE THINGS THAT MAYBE
WOULDN'T HAVE BOTHERED US
IN THE VERY BEGINNING
WHEN WE WERE JUST STARTING OFF
ARE JUST IRRITATING NOW.
YOU DIDN'T LET ME FINISH.
I WANT TO FINISH.
♪♪♪
WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
"IN THIS
MODELING COMPETITION,
EVERY STEP COUNTS.
BE READY AT 9:45 A.M."
"EVERY STEP COUNTS"?
HOW OBVIOUS IS THAT?
IT'S OBVIOUS? WHAT IS IT?
IS THAT THAT CHOCOLATE THING?
WHAT?
EATING IS LIKE-- I DON'T KNOW,
IT MAKES ME FEEL BETTER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND
OF SYNDROME I HAVE.
IS THAT THAT CHOCOLATE--
WHAT IS THAT IN YOUR HAND?
YEAH,
IT'S A CHOCOLATE MUFFIN.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
WITH THE TYRA MAIL?
YOU REALLY THINK IT'S
THAT OBVIOUS?
YOU THINK IT'S RUNWAY AGAIN?
I HOPE IT IS.
NOW, I REAL, LIKE-- CAN I HAVE
A LITTLE PIECE OF IT?
UH-HUH.
WOULD YOU FINISH,
YOUR GOSH DARN THOUGHT?
I FEEL LIKE IT'S GONNA BE
A RUNWAY SHOW.
I DON'T THINK KEENYAH
IS WATCHING WHAT SHE EATS.
THAT'S WHAT THE JUDGES
KEEP TELLING HER,
IT'S WHAT THEY KEEP
COMPLAINING ABOUT.
AND I REALLY DON'T SEE
THAT MUCH PROGRESS... AT ALL.
♪♪♪
CAN I WEAR THIS, UM,
WHAT'S YOUR NAME, BRITTANY?
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
YOU CAN BORROW WHATEVER
YOU WANT OF MINE.
BECAUSE I'M SPECIAL.
SAY "BECAUSE YOU'RE SPECIAL"
AT THE END OF IT.
SAY IT AGAIN.
'CAUSE YOU'RE SPECIAL.
COOL. COOL, COOL, COOL.
♪♪♪
RIGHT HERE, GUYS.
HI, YOU GUYS.
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
GOOD. HOW ARE YOU?
I'M FINE. I AM BEBE.
HE IS MANDELA MOKOENA.
PLEASURE TO MEET YOU.
TOGETHER,
WE'RE THE COFOUNDERS
OF G'MBO URBAN ETHNIC CLOTHING.
IT'S A PROUDLY
SOUTH AFRICAN BRAND,
SOUTH AFRICA COMES FROM
A PRETTY ROUGH BACKGROUND.
WE JUST GOT DEMOCRACY
JUST ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO.
SO WE WANTED TO WEAR SOMETHING
THAT WOULD REFLECT WHO WE ARE
AND WHERE WE COME FROM
AND WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SHOW YOU
WHAT IT IS LIKE IN THE TOWNSHIPS
AND WHERE WE DERIVE
SOME OF OUR INSPIRATION.
THESE ARE
THE INFORMAL SETTLEMENTS,
SHACKS.
A TOWNSHIP IS BASICALLY
WHAT WE CALL THE GHETTO
BACK IN AMERICA.
IT'S LIKE LITTLE METAL,
LIKE SHACKS LIKE
WITH PLASTIC BAGS FOR ROOFS.
THEY'RE NOT
LIKE THIS, THOUGH.
THIS IS, TO ME, VERY EXTREME.
YEAH.
THIS IS NOT DECENT LIVING
BY ANY MEANS AND STANDARDS.
NOT WHAT?
DECENT LIVING.
THIS IS NOT-- THIS IS NOT LIFE.
YOU SEE IT ON TV,
BUT WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY IN IT,
AND YOU SEE IT, IT'S LIKE,
WOW, THIS REALLY DOES EXIST.
WE SHOW UP
AT THE COMMUNITY CENTER
IN THE TOWNSHIP.
(speaking indistinctly)
THIS IS JACKIE FROM JAZZ ART.
HI, I'M JACKIE MANYAPELO.
HI.
WE'RE THE JAZZ ART
DANCE THEATER.
TODAY YOU'LL BE LEARNING
ABOUT RHYTHM AND DANCE.
I GOTTA SAY, I DO NOT KNOW
HOW THIS IS GONNA GO.
YOU'LL BE PAIRED UP
WITH AN INSTRUCTOR,
SO LET'S GET STARTED.
I HATE DANCING.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT TRIBAL DANCING IS.
YOU DON'T WANT ME
BECAUSE I CAN'T DANCE.
I KNOW.
THIS IS GONNA BE EMBARRASSING.
OKAY.
(gives dance commands)
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT
THAT THERE WAS A CONNECTION
BETWEEN DANCE AND MODELING.
IT HELPS YOU REALIZE YOUR BODY
AS A WHOLE PIECE OF MOVEMENT.
UP, CATCH.
I'M IN AFRICA
WHERE MY PEOPLE ARE FROM,
SO I SHOULD FEEL
EVEN MORE EMPOWERED,
LIKE I AM WHERE I'M FROM NOW.
AND SO I REALLY SHOULD BRING IT.
OH!
MY JEANS ARE TOO TIGHT.
I DON'T DANCE.
NOT AT ALL.
ESPECIALLY NOT
AFRICAN TRIBAL DANCE.
I CAN'T GET INTO THE MOTIONS YET
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW LIKE
WHAT I'M DOING.
KICK.
I AM JUST WIGGLING AROUND
UP THERE.
WHEN THINGS GET TOO HARD
IN MY LIFE, YOU KNOW, I GIVE UP
BECAUSE I DON'T EVER
WANT TO FAIL.
KAHLEN LET IT BUILD
AND BUILD AND BUILD.
IT MADE HER FEEL EVEN WORSE
ABOUT YOURSELF.
I NEED A WATER.
IS THIS YOUR FIRST TIME
IN AFRICA FOR ALL OF YOU?
MM-HMM, ALL OF US.
IT'S GOOD TO COME HERE.
NOT THAT IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO ME THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BLACK.
I'M BLACK.
KEENYAH'S JUST LIKE, "I'M BLACK,
I'M BLACK,
AND THIS MEANS A LOT TO ME."
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
"WELL, KEENYAH,
DON'T YOU SEE ME SITTING HERE?"
OF COURSE, I DON'T HAVE
DARK BROWN SKIN,
BUT MY FATHER IS BLACK,
AND MEXICAN INDIAN,
AND MY MOM IS BLACK AND IRISH.
COMING FROM AMERICA,
BEING BLACK, LIKE
I WAS LIKE, "BEFORE I DIE
I HAVE TO GO TO AFRICA."
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HOME.
SOME OF THEM ARE SAYING
TO ME LIKE, "WELCOME HOME,
WELCOME HOME," AND THEY'RE NOT
SAYING IT TO THE OTHER GIRLS.
I FEEL VERY GOOD
THAT THEY SAY THAT TO ME.
OKAY.
SO YOU'VE LEARNED THE DANCE.
YOU KNOW IT.
AND NOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
PERFORMING IT
IN FRONT OF AN AUDIENCE.
THERE ARE TIMES WHERE,
YOU KNOW, ULTIMATE
AND TOTAL HUMILIATION
IS JUST NOT SOMETHING
I WANT TO THROW MYSELF INTO.
I DO A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF THAT
BY MYSELF.
IT IS A CHALLENGE,
AND YOU WILL BE JUDGED.
THIS IS ALFRED HINKLE,
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF JAZZ ART.
WE'VE ALSO GOT A SPECIAL GUEST.
(laughter)
WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
HEY.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
IT'S VERY NICE
TO SEE MISS J.,
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DANCE
IN FRONT OF HIM.
YOU GONNA SHOW ME
WHAT YOU GOT?
YES.
OKAY. GOOD.
GO BACK
INTO THE DRESSING ROOM,
GET YOUR COSTUME ON.
IT'S SHOW TIME.
I'M GONNA LOOK
SO GOOFY OUT THERE.
OH, GOD.
DANCING'S ONE THING
I CAN'T DO,
AND I NEVER WANT TO BE
ON THE STAGE DANCING.
I HATE THIS CHALLENGE!
IT'S-- IT'S FRUSTRATING,
REALLY FRUSTRATING FOR ME.
(singing in African language)
TODAY'S CHALLENGE,
WE'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON HOW WELL WE CAN MOVE
AND HOW WELL WE'VE LEARNED
THE ACTUAL CHOREOGRAPHY.
YOU'VE LEARNED THE DANCE,
AND NOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
PERFORMING IT
IN FRONT OF AN AUDIENCE.
I'M JUST LIKE,
"OKAY, LET ME JUST
ROLL WITH THE PUNCHES
AND SEE IF I CAN DO THIS."
(making rattling noise)
♪♪♪
(cheering and screaming)
THE AUDIENCE
DIDN'T LIKE MY DANCE.
I DON'T BLAME THEM.
GOT UP, YOU KNOW,
IN FRONT ON THAT STAGE,
IN FRONT OF THE AUDIENCE.
OF COURSE, I WAS VERY NERVOUS.
BUT I ACTED.
I ACTED THE ENTIRE TIME
I WAS UP THERE
BECAUSE I WAS UNCOMFORTABLE.
KAHLEN NEVER THINKS
THAT SHE DID GOOD
OR SHE'S DOING GOOD
OR DOES GOOD,
AND SHE ALWAYS DOES.
I FEEL VERY HONORED
AND VERY BLESSED TO ACTUALLY
LEARN SOME AFRICAN DANCE.
ME BEING THE ONLY BLACK GIRL,
NOT THAT I APPRECIATE IT
MORE THAN EVERYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BLACK,
BUT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
BEING A QUIET PERSON HAS
ALWAYS BEEN PART OF WHO I AM.
FOR ME, BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
LIKE TRAINING IN BALLET FOR
SO LONG, DANCING HAS GIVEN ME
AN OUTLET TO EXPRESS MYSELF
WITHOUT SPEAKING.
(applause)
TO PERFORM IN FRONT
OF AFRICAN PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE
IN THE TOWNSHIP,
IT WAS LIKE REALLY COOL.
LIKE I FEEL VERY, VERY GOOD
ABOUT MYSELF.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE AUDIENCE--
WHO DO YOU THINK WAS THE BEST?
KEENYAH?
(cheers and applause)
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY.
BRITTANY.
(applause)
KAHLEN.
NAIMA.
(loud cheers and applause)
OUR WINNER TODAY
IS MISS NAIMA.
(applause)
NAIMA REALLY DESERVED IT.
SHE DID A GREAT JOB,
SO I CAN'T BE BITTER,
THOUGH I WOULD LOVE TO BE.
FOR THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION,
YOU GET AN EXTRA 30 FRAMES
ON YOUR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU ALSO GET TO CHOOSE ONE GIRL
THAT WILL GET AN EXTRA 20 FRAMES
ON HER NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
SO WHO WILL BE THE LUCKY GIRL?
KEENYAH.
NAIMA PICKS KEENYAH TO SHARE
THE PRIZE WITH,
AND I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHY.
I HAVE
A VERY STRONG FRIENDSHIP
WITH KAHLEN,
BUT I HAVE TO THINK
AS A COMPETITOR.
HER PICTURES ARE ALREADY GREAT,
AND IF SHE GETS MORE FRAMES,
IT'S GONNA GIVE ME LESS LIKELY
OF A CHANCE OF SURPASSING HER
IN THE PANEL.
NOW, KEENYAH, YOU GET
TO CHOOSE THE GIRL WHO GETS
AN EXTRA TEN FRAMES
ON HER NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
BRITTANY.
MISS BRITTANY,
YOU GET TO TELL
MISS KAHLEN THAT SHE GETS NADA.
SHE TAKES FABULOUS PICTURES,
SHE DOESN'T NEED
ANY EXTRA FRAMES.
SO, GIRLS, CONGRATULATIONS
AND GOOD LUCK.
(cheers and applause)
YOU DID BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
REALLY, WHY DID YOU PICK ME?
'CAUSE YOU THINK I COULD
GET HELP IF I HAVE
EXTRA FRAMES, RIGHT?
AND SO I GET PICKED LAST,
AND I DON'T GET ANYTHING.
IS THIS SOME KIND
OF SMALL ATTACK ON ME?
YOU OKAY?
YEAH, I'M FINE.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
WHAT IS THEIR MOTIVES
FOR DOING THIS?
ARE THEY, YOU KNOW, JUST TRYING
TO GET RID OF ME?
I JUST HOPE THAT THE REST OF
THIS COMPETITION GOES BY FAST,
BECAUSE IT'S JUST
REALLY STARTING TO WEAR ON ME.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
OKAY.
"46664.
"BE READY AT 11:00 A.M.
TYRA."
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
I KNOW WHAT 666 IS,
BUT WHAT THE HELL IS THE 4s?
46664-- I'M NOT
REALLY SURE WHAT IT MEANS.
IT COULD BE A PIZZA
DELIVERY BOY'S PHONE NUMBER.
♪♪♪
HI.
WELCOME TO ROBBEN ISLAND.
MY NAME IS MODISE,
AND ROBBEN ISLAND BASICALLY
WAS MY HOME FOR FIVE YEARS
ROBBEN ISLAND WAS A PRISON.
WE FIND OUT
THAT ROBBEN ISLAND WAS
A POLITICAL PRISON
WHEN THERE WAS A LOT OF LIKE
RACIAL SEGREGATION AND STUFF
GOING ON.
A LOT OF PAIN,
LOT OF BEATING,
LOT OF TORTURE.
ROBBEN ISLAND WAS
NELSON MANDELA'S HOME
FOR A PERIOD OF 18 YEARS.
NELSON MANDELA WAS A MAN
WHO WAS A TRIBAL CHIEF.
ULTIMATELY BECAME A LAWYER
TO BE IN THE STRUGGLE.
HE WAS ARRESTED,
BROUGHT TO ROBBEN ISLAND.
ON HIS RELEASE,
HE ROSE FROM THE ASHES
OF ROBBEN ISLAND
TO BECOME THE FIRST
ELECTED STATE PRESIDENT IN 1994
IN A NEW DEMOCRATIC
SOUTH AFRICA.
AS WE CAME HERE, YOU WILL BE
GIVEN A PRISON NUMBER,
AND THAT WILL BE YOUR IDENTITY.
MR. NELSON MANDELA-- THE NUMBER
IS KNOW AS 4-TRIPLE 6-4.
THE NAME NELSON MANDELA
KEPT MY COUNTRY GOING.
KEPT MY PEOPLE HOPING.
I DIDN'T KNOW
IF NELSON MANDELA, AT THE TIME,
WAS ALIVE
OR NOT ALIVE AT THE MOMENT.
OKAY, GUYS.
KEENYAH ASKED ME, YOU KNOW,
"IS NELSON MANDELA
EVEN STILL ALIVE?"
AND I WAS LIKE, "YEAH."
SO I DIDN'T THINK
THAT SHE KNEW MUCH ABOUT HIM.
TODAY, I HOLD
THE MASTER KEY.
I NEVER DREAMT OF HAVING
THIS KEY IN MY HAND.
ONE OF YOU LADIES WILL HAVE
THE PLEASURE TO OPEN
MR. MANDELA'S CELL.
HE'S LIKE,
"WHICH ONE OF YOU GIRLS
WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO OPEN THE CELL?"
HE HANDS IT TO NAIMA,
YOU KNOW, AS NAIMA'S
WALKING UP TO THE DOOR,
I LIKE I WISH I WAS
OPENING IT.
KEENYAH WANTED TO UNLOCK IT.
YOU KNOW, LIKE SHE THINKS
JUST BECAUSE
SHE'S THE BLACK ONE,
THAT SHE DESERVES TO OPEN IT.
I DON'T REALLY THINK
OF NAIMA AS BLACK.
I JUST DON'T SEE THAT IN HER.
I'M NOT
THE TYPICAL BLACK GIRL,
BUT IT MEANS A LOT FOR ME
BEING HERE.
1964 TO 1982.
JUST THE COURAGE
OF THAT ONE MAN KEPT US GOING.
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK
THAT KEENYAH KNEW WHO HE WAS.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW
IF HE'S ALIVE OR NOT,
SO I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY SHE WAS GETTING
SO EMOTIONAL.
YOU PROBABLY
WEREN'T EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT,
BUT I CRIED
WHEN I WENT IN NELSON--
I WAS IN NELSON MANDELA'S CELL.
DO YOU KNOW HOW BIG THAT IS?
I GUESS.
I MEAN, MAYBE IT REALLY DOES
MEAN A LOT TO KEENYAH.
I JUST FEEL LIKE
IT'S SOMEWHAT FOR SHOW.
I'VE HEARD HER SAY IT
SO MANY TIMES,
"THIS JUST MEANS SO MUCH TO ME
'CAUSE I'M BLACK."
AND IT'S JUST LIKE,
"OKAY, ALL RIGHT, GREAT."
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
YES, TYRA MAIL.
"ARE YOUR FEET AS HEAVY
AS YOUR LUGGAGE?
FIND OUT TOMORROW AT 8:30."
8:30 A.M.?
♪♪♪
HOW YOU GUYS DOIN'?
GOOD.
NO, WE'RE NOT
RIDING OSTRICHES TODAY, OKAY?
LOOK AT 'EM.
ON TODAY'S SHOOT WE'RE DOING
LIKE A 1940s PHOTOGRAPH
FOR CARESS SENSATIONAL
SMOOTHING BODY WASH.
AND THE SETTING IS HERE
AT THIS OSTRICH FARM.
SO YOU GIRLS ARE KIND OF LIKE
THE ARISTOCRATIC WOMEN
ON VACATION IN AFRICA.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME AFRICAN DRUMMERS,
AND YOU GUYS HAVE LEARNED
ALL ABOUT WHAT?
MOVEMENT.
SO TODAY'S REAL CHALLENGE IS
HOW WELL YOU CAN DANCE AND MOVE
AND MAKE IT LOOK BELIEVABLE
AND BEAUTIFUL IN A PHOTOGRAPH.
SO YOU GUYS HAD
A LITTLE COMPETITION THIS WEEK,
AND WHO WON?
NAIMA?
OKAY, SO NORMALLY
WHEN WE DO A PHOTO SHOOT,
WE GIVE EACH OF YOU GIRLS
70 FRAMES.
SO YOU WON 30 EXTRA FRAMES
SO YOU HAVE
A TOTAL OF 100 FRAMES TODAY.
NAIMA DOESN'T NEED
30 EXTRA SHOTS.
SHE'S A GREAT DANCER.
SHE'LL PROBABLY GET IT
ON THE FIRST SHOT.
THEN, KEENYAH,
YOU WON 20 EXTRA FRAMES.
AND, BRITTANY,
YOU HAVE TEN EXTRA FRAMES.
AND, KAHLEN, YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY EXTRA FRAMES.
THAT MEAN YOU GOTTA WORK
THE HARDEST.
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY
IS JOHAN WILKE.
HE HAS SHOT
FOR A LOT OF INTERNATIONAL
FASHION MAGAZINES.
TODAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE
PEOPLE DANCING.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
JUST TO BE YOURSELF, UH, RELAX.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE DANCING
WITH THREE HOT GUYS.
SO THESE ARE YOUR GUYS TODAY.
HELLO.
LEE-ROY, BERTINI, AND MARK.
SO LET'S GO
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
NO.
SO DO YOU WANT TO GO OUT?
DON'T WE, GUYS?
DON'T WE WANT TO GO OUT?
MM-HMM, I WANT TO GO OUT.
WE WANT TO KNOW
HOW PARTYING IS IN SOUTH AFRICA.
OH, YEAH.
IT'LL BE FUN TO GO OUT
WITH THE GUYS FOR DINNER.
WE DON'T GET A LOT OF
INTERACTION WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
BERTINI?
BERTINI, IT'S EASY.
IT'S KIND OF A COOL NAME.
I LIKE THAT NAME.
UH, IT'S KEENYAH?
BERTINI IS
A VERY INTERESTING PERSON.
BEFORE WE GO ONTO THE SHOOT,
LIKE HE'S VERY, VERY FLIRTY.
DO YOU WANT TO GIVE ME
YOUR NUMBER?
I DON'T HAVE ONE.
NO NUMBER?
OKAY, I'LL GIVE YOU MINE.
DO YOU WANT ME
TO TAKE YOUR PICTURE ON MY CELL?
HE'S TRYING TO GET
MY PHONE NUMBER AND HE'S TRYING
TO TAKE A PICTURE OF ME
ON HIS CAMERA PHONE,
AND, UM, IT WAS VERY AWKWARD.
WILL YOU GIVE ME
THAT MASSAGE?
KEENYAH, HE WANTS
A MASSAGE FROM YOU.
SORRY, GOTTA GO RUN
TO WARDROBE AFTER THIS.
YOU NEED TO GO
MICKEY D's-STYLE.
YOU KNOW, I NEED TO
REALLY WATCH WHAT I EAT
SO THAT I CAN GET MY BODY BACK
TO HOW IT WAS
WHEN I FIRST ENTERED
THE COMPETITION.
I FEEL LIKE I AM PRETTY MUCH
STICKING TO MY DIET.
IF THERE ARE ONLY FRENCH FRIES
TO EAT,
I JUST EAT A SMALL AMOUNT
OF FRENCH FRIES.
I THINK THAT SHE HASN'T BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO A LOT
OF THE THINGS SHE'S PUTTING
IN HER MOUTH.
ARE YOU READY THERE, NAIMA?
YOU WANT TO DANCE,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE SOME FUN.
YOU LOOK GREAT, ALL RIGHT?
SO, YOU KNOW,
HAVE FUN WITH THIS.
COULD WE HAVE SOME MUSIC?
(playing drums)
(singing in African language)
CLOSE IN. HERE WE GO.
BECAUSE I'M A DANCER
AND BECAUSE EVERYONE KNOWS THAT,
I REALLY HAVE TO WORK
A LOT HARDER.
IT DEFINITELY PUTS
THE PRESSURE ON.
YOU'RE GIVING
THE PERFECT EXPRESSION.
YOU'RE CONFIDENT,
YOU'RE ALLURING.
I DELIVER WHEN I'M ON
A PHOTO SHOOT.
I NEED TO BRING THAT WITH ME
TO THE PANEL.
NAIMA, WE'RE GONNA GO INTO
YOUR 30 EXTRA FRAMES RIGHT NOW.
WHEN WE GOT INTO THOSE
EXTRA 30 FRAMES,
NAIMA GOT A LITTLE CARRIED AWAY
AND WENT FROM BALLERINA
INTO... SHOWGIRL.
THAT'S IT, JOHAN.
SHE'S GOT A HUNDRED SHOTS.
GIVE ME SPACE NOW.
I GOTTA WORK THIS OUT.
I NEED SOME SPACE.
HEY, GUYS, GET CLOSE.
MUSIC.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS...
I NEED YOU TO BE YOU.
I NEED TO BELIEVE THIS.
I NEED IT TO FEEL CAREFREE,
AND I NEED YOU TO STOP POSING
FOR THE CAMERA.
I'M TRYING TO GET INTO IT,
AND I HEAR BERTINI MOANING.
(moans)
I FEEL HIM LIKE
BREATHING ON ME, TOUCHING ME,
AND IT'S NOT COMFORTABLE AT ALL.
STOP.
WHAT'S THE ISSUE?
I KNOW IT IS NOT ABOUT
FEELING COMFORTABLE,
BUT I HEAR HIM MOANING,
AND IT JUST THREW ME OFF.
MOANING WHERE?
LIKE ON ME.
LIKE I'M SORRY.
I JUST DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE.
IT'S JUST SO AWKWARD
AND VERY DISRESPECTFUL TO ME,
SO I DON'T FEEL WE CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH THE SHOOT.
WHAT'S THE ISSUE?
I KNOW IT'S NOT ABOUT
FEELING COMFORTABLE,
BUT I HEAR HIM MOANING
AND IT JUST THREW ME OFF.
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
I DON'T FEEL BAD ABOUT
STOPPING THE SHOOT AT ALL.
BERTINI HAS CROSSED
THAT PROFESSIONAL LINE,
AND I FEEL
EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE.
WE'RE HERE IN
A PROFESSIONAL SITUATION.
THERE ARE LIKE 50 OF US
SITTING HERE ON SET.
WELL, RIGHT, RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING WITH THE FLOW.
♪♪♪
(singing in African language)
THIS BERTINI GUY--
HE DIDN'T CATCH THE HINT.
HE KEPT DOING IT.
SO THIS IS FOR THE GUYS--
LET'S TRY AND BE INTERESTED
WITHOUT LITERALLY GRABBING
HER BUTT.
I FEEL A LOT OF PRESSURE
ADDED ON TO ME BECAUSE
I CAN END UP BEING ELIMINATED
FOR NOT DOING SO WELL
ON THIS SHOOT
BECAUSE OF HIS ACTIONS.
LAST FRAME.
OKAY, COOL.
I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT
ABOUT BEING COMFORTABLE,
BUT THERE WAS A LINE
THAT I FEEL WAS CROSSED.
AND I HOPE THAT DOESN'T COME OUT
IN MY PICTURE
WHEN I GO TO PANEL.
I'M FINE WITH THE OTHER PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW,
GETTING INTO THE MOMENT,
BUT DON'T FLIRT AND ATTEMPT
TO GET IN MY PANTIES AND...
IF I HAVE TO GO HOME BECAUSE
I DIDN'T MAKE IT SEEM REAL,
THEN I'M GONNA FEEL PROUD
THAT AT LEAST IT WASN'T
'CAUSE OF ME.
IT WASN'T BECAUSE OF ME.
I DON'T THINK
THAT SHE SHOULD HAVE LET
BERTINI AFFECT THE WAY
HER SHOOT'S GOING TO GO.
IT'S NOT FAIR FOR KEENYAH
TO BLAME SOMEONE
OUTSIDE OF HERSELF
FOR HER SHOOT GOING WRONG.
BRITTANY'S PROBABLY
LOVING IT.
I JUST FEEL THAT
I'VE REALLY GOT TO STEP IT UP
'CAUSE NAIMA IS
SUCH A GREAT DANCER.
SO I'VE JUST GOT
TO GET A GOOD SHOT.
I CAN'T USE A SHOT
WITH YOUR ARMS
STRAIGHT UP LIKE THIS, EH?
SO IF YOU HAVE YOUR ARMS UP,
DO SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S LOOKING LIKE-- WHOO!
THE SHOOT'S VERY AWKWARD,
AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I AM DOING IT GOOD OR NOT.
THAT WAS
A WHOLE LOT OF NOTHIN'.
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE HAD EXTRA FRAMES TODAY,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO BE NERVOUS.
I HAVE A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON ME BECAUSE I HAVE LESS FRAMES
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS,
AND THERE ARE ALL
THESE MALE MODELS,
AND THAT MAKES ME
A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE,
AND I CAN'T DANCE.
I WANT YOU TO GET IN
THE SCENE WITH THIS.
I DON'T KNOW REALLY
WHY I DO HAVE
THIS DISCOMFORT AROUND BOYS.
THAT'S THE WAY I AM, YOU KNOW.
I'M NOT EVER LOOKED AT
LIKE THE SEXY GIRL.
SO IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO THINK OF MYSELF THAT WAY.
LESS POSEY, KAHLEN,
AND A LITTLE MORE DANCE.
KAHLEN NEEDS TO LEARN HOW TO
TRUST HERSELF MORE.
SHE CAN'T WALK ONTO A SET
SUPER NERVOUS
AND DOUBTING HERSELF.
I THINK IT WENT OKAY.
IT FEEL MORE LIKE DANCING
THAN POSING TOP ME,
WHICH WAS A LITTLE STRANGE
'CAUSE I'M A POSER,
NOT A DANCER.
I KNOW THAT WAS A LOT
FOR YOU TO LET OUT.
HOW WAS IT FOR YOU?
AWKWARD.
I DID THIS ONE.
♪♪♪
I WENT INTO DINNER
LIKE, "WE'RE GONNA HAVE FUN.
"THESE GUYS ARE COOL
TO HANG OUT WITH,
THEY WERE COOL ON SET, WHY NOT?"
HEY, GUYS. WHAT'S UP?
FIRST THING I SEE IS BERTINI.
OH, WHY?
I DO NOT WANT TO SEE THIS GUY.
HE'S SO OBNOXIOUS.
IT'S GONNA BE
A VERY IRRITATING NIGHT.
HE WAS FULL ON--
YOU GOT IT SOFT, THOUGH.
INTIMATE-- YOU WERE MOANING,
AND I FELT YOU ON MY THIGH.
THERE'S A LINE.
WAS IT A THIN LINE?
NO, IT WAS
A PRETTY THICK LINE.
YEAH, OF COURSE IT IS.
IT WAS PRETTY DARN THICK.
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE
THE PICTURE HOT.
YOU DID GOOD.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
I DIDN'T MIND YOU AT ALL.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE FABULOUS.
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE
THE PICTURE HOT.
BRITTANY, GUZZLE YOUR DRINK.
WHERE IS IT, ALREADY GUZZLED?
GUZZLE SOME MORE.
DINNER STINKS.
DINNER IS AWFUL.
THE FOOD'S GREAT,
THE CONVERSATION STINKS.
THIS TABLE HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY AWKWARD.
OH, THAT'S THE BILL.
WHICH ONE IS MINE ON HERE?
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
KEENYAH, DID YOU ALREADY PAY?
MY THING'S NOT ON THE BILL.
BUT ARE YOU GONNA ADD--
MY-- WHAT I DRANK
IS NOT ON THERE.
IT'S JUST LIKE
POLITE TO ADD.
YEAH.
WELL, WHAT DO YOU NEED?
I DON'T HAVE RAND.
WHO COMES TO DINNER
WITH NO MONEY?
YOU KNOW WHAT, BRITTANY,
I FEEL TENSION RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
SO WE COULD JUST NOT TALK
RIGHT NOW.
GREAT. FEEL YOUR TENSION.
JUST SQUASH IT.
WALLOW AROUND IN THE TENSION.
THESE POOR GUYS ARE JUST
SITTING THERE LOOKING AT US
BASH EACH OTHER.
CHANGE SOMETHING, PLEASE.
OKAY.
AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I AM SEEING HER PERSONALITY
MORE AND MORE,
AND THE SELFISH FACTOR--
IT'S DRIVING ME INSANE.
I THINK I CAN SEE THINGS
SOMETIMES THAT ARE FAKE,
AND I SEE FAKENESS RIGHT NOW.
LITTLE AWKWARD.
YOU'RE VERY SELFISH,
VERY MUCH.
LIKE YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY,
BUT YOU ORDER DRINKS.
HOW WERE YOU GONNA PAY
FOR YOUR DRINKS THEN?
EXPLAIN THAT.
HOW?
LET ME TELL YOU THIS.
HOW, NO, HOW?
BRITTANY...
HOW, HOW, WITH WHAT?
THIS IS VERY AWKWARD.
THIS IS VERY INTERESTING.
NO, YELLING ABOUT IT
IS NOT GONNA CHANGE IT,
SO IF YOU WANNA THINK
THAT I'M SELFISH,
YOU GO AHEAD
AND THINK THAT I'M SELFISH.
ARE YOU LISTENING?
NO.
IT JUST GOES BACK
TO HER SELFISH TENDENCIES,
LIKE IN NELSON MANDELA'S
JAIL CELL,
YOU JUST AUTOMATICALLY THINK
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE BLACK
THAT YOU SHOULD BE THE ONE
THAT OPENS THE CELL.
I KNOW THIS EXPERIENCE MEANS
A LOT TO NAIMA AS WELL.
YOU DIDN'T LIKE
THAT SHE GOT THE KEY.
WHEN HE GAVE HER THE KEY,
YOU CRIED ABOUT IT.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
IF HE WAS STILL ALIVE OR NOT.
WHATEVER.
BUT YOU ARE
SO EMOTIONAL OVER SOMEONE
THAT YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
IS ALIVE OR DEAD.
I HATE LISTENING TO PEOPLE
YELL AND JUST SCREAM
AT EACH OTHER,
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER WAYS,
YOU KNOW, TO DEAL
WITH THAT STUFF.
AFTER SHE OPENED THE KEY,
IT WAS EMOTIONAL MOMENT FOR ME.
YOU WERE NOT IN MY SHOES.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW I FELT
AT THAT MOMENT,
SO YOU GO AHEAD AND SAY,
"SHE FELT ANNOYED."
I'M THINKING IN MY HEAD,
"WOW, THANK GOD, NAIMA,
"YOU GOT TO HOLD THAT KEY
IN YOUR HAND,
"BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THESE GIRLS
DON'T HOLD THAT EXPERIENCE
IN SUCH HIGH ESTEEM AS YOU DO."
YOU ARE JUST TAKING THIS
'CAUSE YOU'RE BLACK.
YOU'VE SAID IT A MILLION TIMES.
"THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE TO ME
'CAUSE I AM BLACK."
YEAH, IT'S MORE TO ME
BECAUSE THESE ARE MY ROOTS.
THIS IS WHERE I CAME FROM.
YEAH, WHAT YOU THINK?
YEAH, 'CAUSE I'M BLACK!
OH, MY GOD!
WHAT THE HELL--
SHUT UP!
WILL YOU LET ME
EXPLAIN MYSELF
SO I CAN TALK HERE?
I AM, I AM.
BRITTANY AND KEENYAH ARE
ARGUING WITH EACH OTHER
OVER WHAT HAPPENED
AT NELSON MANDELA'S CELL
THE PREVIOUS DAY,
AND IT PISSED ME OFF.
YOU GOT ALL TEARY-EYED
BECAUSE SHE OPENED
HIS JAIL CELL.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS YOU BEING,
"WHY DOES SHE GET TO OPEN IT?"
OH, YOU THOUGHT I WAS CRYING
BECAUSE I COULDN'T OPEN
THE JAIL CELL?
YES, BECAUSE YOU'RE BLACK,
AND SHE'S WHATEVER.
WE NEED
TO RESPECT EACH OTHER.
WE BOTH HAVE DIFFERENT
CULTURAL EXPERIENCES,
AND MAYBE, MAYBE...
CAN I JUST...
YOU KNOW, ALL RIGHT.
I'M NOT ASKING A QUESTION.
YOU WERE TRYING TO TALK.
I'M TRYING TO LISTEN TO NAIMA.
I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR IT, KEENYAH.
I KNOW WHATEVER
YOU HAVE TO SAY IS GONNA BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I HAVE TO STOP THIS
RIGHT HERE.
THAT EXPERIENCE YESTERDAY
THAT I HAD WAS TOO IMPORTANT.
PLEASE, KEENYAH AND BRITTANY,
DON'T TALK ABOUT THIS ANYMORE.
I'M OVER THE KEY MOMENT, TOO,
SO GIVE ME ANOTHER EXAMPLE,
SO CAN BETTER MYSELF
IF I AM, IN FACT, SELFISH.
WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE
YELL AND SCREAM,
I REALLY DO JUST WANT
TO SEPARATE MYSELF.
DON'T LET LITTLE THINGS
ADD UP
AND THEN AT NIGHT LIKE THIS
HAPPEN TO SAY, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE SELFISH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH HAPPENED."
LET ME KNOW AT THE MOMENT.
IT'S JUST UNFAIR
THAT I'M THE ONLY ONE
THAT WILL SPEAK UP.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TO LEAVE THE ROOM
BECAUSE YOU FEEL THAT WAY.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
I'M THE ONLY ONE
WHO'S SAYING ANYTHING.
I WAS GREAT FRIENDS
WITH BRITTANY,
BUT THIS IS
A NEW SIDE OF BRITTANY
THAT I'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE,
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS ME.
THERE'S TYRA MAIL HERE,
GIRLS.
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
"IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
WE ARE ALL STRESSED OUT,
AND THE PRESSURE IS DEFINITELY
STARTING TO PILE ON.
WE'RE JUST READY FOR THERE
TO BE A WINNER,
AND LET'S DO THIS.
WELCOME, LADIES.
HI.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR 11th CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
FROM TOP INTERNATIONAL MODEL
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE, YOU'VE GROWN
TO KNOW THESE JUDGES VERY WELL.
THE FIRST IS
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODELS.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
HI, LADIES.
NOLE MARIN,
PROMINENT FASHION EDITOR
AND STYLIST.
AND OF COURSE, YOU CAN SEE
OUR GORGEOUS GUEST JUDGES
OVER HERE-- MANDELA AND BEBE.
THESE GUYS ARE THE DESIGNERS
OF AN AMAZING URBAN ETHNIC
CLOTHING LINE CALLED G'MBO.
HI, LADIES.
HI.
NOW AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
YOU'VE BEEN MOVING ALL WEEK,
AND YOU KNOW THAT ONE
OF THE BIGGEST REQUIREMENTS
FOR A MODEL IS THAT
SHE NEEDS TO KNOW HOW TO MOVE,
SO TODAY YOU ARE GOING
TO BE DANCING TOGETHER,
NOT NECESSARILY IN UNISON
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU'RE GONNA BE MOVING,
MOVING, MOVING, MOVING,
AND BAM, POSING
WHEN I CALL FOR YOU TO POSE.
ARE YOU READY?
LET'S GO!
(drum beating)
AND POSE!
(drum stops)
GO!
(drum beating)
POSE!
(drum stops)
AND GO!
(drum beating)
MORE, UP, UP, GO!
WORK IT!
WORK IT, COME ON!
YOU GUYS ARE WACK!
COME ON, MORE ENERGY!
AND POSE!
(drum stops)
(drum beating)
COME ON, UP, JANICE!
UP, NIGEL!
WORK IT!
WHOO, COME ON!
WHOO!
NOLE, NOLE!
GO, NIGEL!
JANICE, GO, JANICE!
MANDELA, MANDELA!
(applause)
WHOO!
I NEEDED THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
FIRST IS BRITTANY.
BRITT, YOU WERE REALLY
HOLDING BACK.
YOU COULD HAVE JUST GIVEN
A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUMP AND GRIND.
I DON'T SEE ANY ENERGY
IN YOUR FACE.
PERSONALITY IS
JUST NOT THERE.
WHERE'S MY BRITTANY?
MY GIRL NEEDED TO LIKE REALLY
SPICE IT UP A LITTLE BIT MORE.
ALL RIGHT, BRITTANY,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU LOOK GREAT, BRITTANY.
I AM SEEING A DIFFERENT SIDE
TO YOU.
THIS IS HIGH FASHION TO ME.
IT'S
AN OUTSTANDING PHOTOGRAPH.
YOU HAD A LOT OF SHOTS
WITH YOUR ARM UP
REALLY BEAUTIFUL LIKE THIS
WHEN YOU WERE CALM.
BUT WHEN YOU WERE TOLD
TO GIVE ENERGY,
YOU KIND OF LOST IT,
AND WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF ALL
THE GIRLS' POOR SHOTS TODAY
AND THEIR MOVEMENT.
GREAT.
THAT WAS YOU GIVING ENERGY.
AND YOU KNOW,
ENERGY DOESN'T MEAN, "WHOO!"
IT MEANS, YOU KNOW,
"HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY."
RIGHT.
KEENYAH.
I COULDN'T KEEP
MY EYES OFF YOU,
'CAUSE YOU WERE SMART ENOUGH
TO STEP OUT OF THE PACK.
IT WAS LIKE,
"BOO, THIS IS A COMPETITION."
IT'S SOMETHING
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE DONE.
YOUR MOVEMENT WAS SO SEXY.
YOU LOOKED LIKE
A DEEP CUP OF HOT CHOCOLATE.
I JUST WANTED TO SIP YOU DOWN,
BUT YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE GONNA BAKE COOKIES
IN THIS OUTFIT.
WRONG COLOR.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT'S A GOOD SHOT,
KIND OF SLANTING SHOT.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE SEEN MORE NECK.
YEAH, MORE NECK,
MORE MOVEMENT.
THE THING IS,
IS THAT THIS MALE MODEL BERTINI,
HE WAS FLIRTING WITH ME.
HE WAS GRINDING ON ME.
I FELT LIKE
HE REALLY CROSSED THE LINE.
THERE HAS TO BE A WAY
THAT YOU CAN HANDLE IT.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO BE IN CONTROL.
LIKE WITH
YOUR FEMININE WILES, LIKE,
"BOY, YOU BEST BACK UP
BEFORE I KNOCK YOU
UPSIDE THE HEAD."
BUT YOU DO IT IN A FUN WAY
WHERE HE KNOWS
TO BACK THE HECK UP,
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY PUT STATIC
IN THE AIR, 'CAUSE THEN
IT MAKES YOU UNCOMFORTABLE.
IF THERE'S SOMEONE
WHO'S HARASSING YOU,
THEN IT CAN MANIFEST ITSELF
IN THE PHOTOS,
BUT IT DOESN'T SHOW.
IT'S EXTREMELY PROFESSIONAL.
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE WHAT
YOUR BAD THING WAS.
TUMMY ACTION AGAIN.
YOU LEARN HOW
TO SUCK IT IN, GIRLFRIEND.
I GOT THE SAME STOMACH, GIRL,
BUT I KNOW HOW TO HOLD IT IN
LIKE WHEN I'M MODELING.
YOU GOT TO WORK
WITH WHAT YOU GOT.
ALL RIGHT, KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, AFRICAN BIRDS
HAVE MORE RHYTHM.
I CALLED YOU
THE SALTINE CRACKER DANCER.
YOU WERE VERY SQUARE
AND VERY DRY.
IT WAS PRETTY STRANGE
TO MY EYES.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
FOR ME, IT'S NOT
MY FAVORITE SHOT OF YOU.
YOU LOOK A LITTLE SCARED.
SOMETIMES THE SEXY THING
IS A LITTLE HARD FOR ME.
OH, KNOCK IT OFF!
THERE IS A WAY OF JUST LIKE
LINING THOSE BOYS UP
AND MESSING UP THEIR HAIR
AND PULLING DOWN THEIR G-STRINGS
AND DANCING
AND HAVING A GOOD TIME.
SO, YEAH, KAHLEN,
YOU HAD SOME BAD ONES.
AS A MODEL, YOU NEED
TO EMBODY YOUR ENVIRONMENT,
AND YOU'RE NOT MODELING
WITH THESE GUYS.
YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE JUST STANDING THERE
WAITING FOR A BUS.
BECAUSE OF A CHALLENGE,
YOU HAD THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF FRAMES,
AND, KAHLEN, YOU NEEDED
THOSE EXTRA FRAMES BADLY.
NAIMA.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
AND YOU DANCE WELL,
BUT YOU WERE HIDDEN.
YOU NEED TO MAKE YOURSELF
GET OUT IN FRONT.
I'VE SEEN YOU DANCE
IN THAT CASTING ROOM
IN LOS ANGELES,
BUT NOW YOU WERE
SO HOLDING BACK.
WHAT WAS HOLDING YOU BACK?
I DON'T KNOW.
YES, YOU DO.
I DON'T THINK
I WAS CONCENTRATED.
YOU WERE CONCENTRATED
OR CONSTIPATED?
NAIMA, YOU'RE
A PROFESSIONAL DANCER, RIGHT?
DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN POINTED TO
FOR A CALLBACK?
NOT TODAY.
NOT TODAY,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
THAT IS SPICY PEPPER.
YOU CONTROLLED THIS PICTURE.
I'M LOOKING RIGHT AT YOU.
YOUR BODY LOOKS FANTASTIC.
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEEDED TO DO
IN FRONT OF US JUST NOW.
STEP OUT.
LET'S SEE YOUR BAD ONES.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
YOU HAD 100 SHOTS,
BUT YOU DIDN'T NEED A 100 SHOTS.
SOMEBODY ELSE BEHIND YOU
NEEDED 100, BUT NOT YOU.
HAD THIS BEEN AN AUDITION
TODAY, I WOULD NOT HAVE
BOOKED YOU TO DO THIS,
AND I WOULD HAVE
MISSED THIS SHOT.
KAHLEN.
THIS IS NOT
MY FAVORITE PICTURE OF KAHLEN.
SHE LOOKS SCARED HERE.
BUT I THINK KAHLEN
IS VERSATILE.
I LOVE THE PICTURE.
SHE'S VERY ECLECTIC.
BRITTANY.
THIS PHOTO OF BRITTANY
IS FLAWLESS.
I THINK HER PERSONALITY
IS SHRINKING.
I WANT A BIT OF
THE OLD BRITTANY TO COME BACK.
BRITTANY HAS MORE
PERSONALITY THAN ANYBODY
IN THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY.
NAIMA.
NAIMA TAKES
GORGEOUS PHOTOGRAPHS.
THE ATTITUDE TODAY
DIDN'T SUPPORT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THIS PICTURE.
WHO IS NAIMA?
I DON'T KNOW THAT I KNOW YET.
SHE'S LIKE A FABERGE EGG.
SHE'S SO GORGEOUS AND GLITTERING
ON THE OUTSIDE.
BUT INSIDE IT'S EMPTY,
AND SHE MAY CRACK.
KEENYAH.
SHE WALKS IN,
AND SHE LOOKS LIKE A TOP MODEL.
NO, SHE LOOKS PUDGY.
BY AFRICAN STANDARDS,
SHE WOULD BE
THE SKINNIEST GIRL ALIVE.
BY AFRICAN-AMERICAN
STANDARDS, SHE'D BE SKINNY, TOO.
YOU SAW HER EYE CONTACT
AT DANCING.
SHE JUST STEPPED UP.
SHE DIDN'T HESITATE.
BY THE WAY, MANDELA,
I LOVE WATCHING YOU SPEAK, LIKE
YOUR LIPS, THEY'RE LIKE,
"SHE DIDN'T HESITATE."
(laughs)
OH, THERE SHE GOES AGAIN,
THAT TYRA.
OH, MY GOSH.
ARE YOU BLUSHING?
BLACK GUYS DON'T BLUSH.
I HAVE FOUR VERY BEAUTIFUL
GIRLS STANDING BEFORE ME,
AND AS YOU KNOW, I ONLY HAVE
THREE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE THREE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
KEENYAH.
KEENYAH, YOUR PERFORMANCE TODAY
IN THIS ROOM SHOWED THAT
IF YOU SAY, "I AM IT.
"I AM BEAUTIFUL,
AND I'M GONNA TAKE THE SPOTLIGHT
AND PROVE IT TO YOU,"
SOMETIMES IT MAKES THE JUDGES
TURN THEIR HEADS AWAY
FROM THE LITTLE EXTRA OOMPH
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
IN OUR MIDSECTION.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, YOU'RE ALMOST
A COMPLETE PACKAGE,
BUT A TOP MODEL'S GOT
TO BE SEXY.
THEY HAVE TO TO HAVE A FIRE
INSIDE, AND THEY CAN'T BE
AFRAID OF THAT FIRE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL NAIMA AND BRITTANY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NEITHER OF YOUR COMMENTS
ARE ABOUT YOUR PHOTOS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THIS.
'CAUSE YOU, BRITTANY,
YOU WALKED IN WITH SO MUCH FIRE,
AND NOW THE JUDGES JUST SEE
SOMEONE THAT'S SLIPPING AWAY,
SOMEONE WHOSE PASSION AND DESIRE
MAY NOT BE THERE
LIKE IT USED TO BE.
AND, NAIMA, WITH YOU,
THE JUDGES SEE A FIRE
THAT IS BURNING VERY WEAKLY.
THE JUDGES STILL SAY
THEY DON'T KNOW NAIMA.
AND IF THEY STILL DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
HOW ARE YOU GONNA RELATE
TO ALL OF AMERICA?
AND I DON'T DOUBT THAT EITHER
OF YOU HAVE PASSION FOR THIS,
BUT ONE GIRL'S PASSION
SEEMS TO BE DWINDLING,
AND THE OTHER GIRL'S PASSION
SEEMS TO BE STIFLED.
NAIMA.
WE KNOW IT'S THERE.
I SEE IT,
BUT THESE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
HAVE TO SEE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, BRITTANY.
I LOVE YOU.
SORRY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S LIKE
OFFICIALLY OVER FOR ME NOW.
I'M GONNA MISS LIKE
GETTING ALL LIKE DONE UP,
THE FUN COSTUMES
AND LIKE THE PHOTO SHOOTS.
I LIKE THE SHOOTS.
AND I'M GONNA MISS THAT.
I'M GONNA REALLY,
REALLY MISS THAT.
I'M GONNA MISS PROBABLY
KEENYAH THE MOST.
WE CALL EACH OTHER SISTERS,
LIKE WE'RE SO MUCH ALIKE.
I'M PROUD OF MYSELF
FOR MAKING IT THIS FAR,
SO I CAN LOOK AT THE GOOD.
IT'S JUST HARD
WHEN YOU'RE SO CLOSE
AND YET SO FAR.
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP, IT'S FINALE WEEK
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ON TUESDAY, CATCH SOME
NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN FOOTAGE...
THIS IS REALLY HURTING.
...AS WE TAKE YOU THROUGH
HOW WE GOT FROM 14 GIRLS
TO 3 FINALISTS.
AND ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT,
KEENYAH, NAIMA, AND KAHLEN
DUKE IT OUT
IN A COVER GIRL COMMERCIAL...
ENERGY, PLEASE!
...AND A CAPE TOWN
FASHION SHOW,
ALL LEADING UP
TO THE FINAL DECISION.
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
FIND OUT NEXT WEEK.